all right and we are live
flashpoint ebon tease the moment has
arrived it's good over ah man every
waking moment I have been buried and
forsaken like you've been doing the same
but no I don't want to sleep I have to
but I don't want to talk about it Oh
same thing it's just been it's scary how
much it would affect the game that it's
really requested certain things we had
to say to man it feels good it feels
good it's back and you know been playing
non-stop it is just a tremendous feeling
and just to see you know people come
back and odd or at least even ask me how
things are looking
you know that kind of thing so it is a
good time babe we got a lot to discuss
so much to talk about
last last long point we'll see how it
goes yeah late change for you guys I'm
just out in the morning and with timings
and stuff like that so we wanted to get
it in tonight so if you guys don't catch
this one live or you listen to it later
thank you for watching it where have you
guys watch it and as always follow us on
all the social yes yeah I don't know
let's just jump in words are like this
one heads up we're gonna try and keep
this one
spoiler light we're not gonna deep dive
we'll give that maybe a week or two to a
really at least one more week till we
kind of go into full story discussion
but so a heads up if you're listening if
there's anything we think we're gonna
say try and give a heads up so we'll try
and give you guys a listening point to
be like a FY big spoiler coming that way
but
we'll turn now they do too much of this
week so you guys can just enjoy then
maybe next week we'll deep dive on a
couple story items and stuff absolutely
man same thing you so we'll definitely
go like spoilers and we get into so long
where you want to saw you when you start
with our basic experience or you just
want to Table eight how you want to jump
off uh we'll save the twelve because
honestly everybody just like it's
forsaking the expansion's out the swab
is pretty light we'll cover a couple
things and now which are later
but generally I just want like I mean
just come out and hit me house has a bit
then it's it's been fantastic it's been
is it's just a breath of fresh air it's
um I remember just early in the campaign
you know you know just getting my first
random roll drop and just seeing how
much I missed that experience but let's
get to the chase I mean obviously what
we're here for is obviously the whole
cave situation and what has transpired
again like spoilers not gonna go too
deep I want people who haven't
experienced it to really experience it
but um I just thought it was so well
done man I thought it was really well
done I was definitely um I felt the
scope of the prison was really really
done well I thought there was like huge
yes I thought there were very cool
touches with the ads you're very like
cellblock D a little tidbit here and
there oh details and you know for all in
terms of purposes I Kay gets to shine
and it you just like damn and another
thing too um I want to give I know like
there's a big civil war in the ghost
dinklebot Nolan by community come on
y'all listen I'm not disrespecting think
about I will never disrespected him I
always just said in that situation that
he you know was put in a situation where
I don't know if it was one of the guys
that they did that writers but or it was
just one of those situations where he
didn't have enough time and you know
because Game of Thrones or whatever but
Nolan by says he's come on I know people
there's people like me who love him and
then his people like II mean it's like
other people that disagree when he says
he doesn't shut up and too much jokes
and yada yada yada all I will say is
this if you want to respect the man's
craft that man is doing Kate
oh yeah no yeah that's important not
even think about wait a minute that's
not nathan fillion right now and still
pull it off i mean like you and let you
the hardcore destiny guy like you can
tell a little bit of the different
inflection or certain there's there are
a couple twinges but
overall like if you don't just deep dive
on yes so um like I said that and you
know story was great you know we got we
got to where we got to the moment so to
speak
and um you know rapper style too man
yeah like I won't say much more than
that but I wouldn't I wouldn't invest
for one certain thing that happen any
other way absolutely man absolutely I
mean he stole the show you know
definitely missed and then you know as
far as the aftermath oh boy it is the
morning that we haven't seen in trailers
a little bit more but um just when I
thought I wasn't pissed off with a
certain Vanguard again the campaign for
those who you know get to that point
there is something that happens with a
certain member of the Vanguard who I am
pissed off beyond belief that he even
it's like he rubs it in your face and I
was just like oh man I already know what
I'm talking about but it's just like so
so me and do got problems but that's not
story but I mean just you can't pay for
that I mean obviously things change the
game that the tangled sure it just
really cool you know the new public
events all that good stuff
um spider you know I'm saying and um I
will say this though spiders running a
real hustle right now for masterwork
[ __ ] bro little tip to everybody if
you have a decent amount of shards by
one masterwork a day and do that now
because if you buy more than one that
stuff escalates real fast
4080 yes now I say he doubles the price
I he knows he's got the hottest product
in town and every time you come back he
doubles the price so I would advise what
I did is once he got to like 80 asking
for like 80 shards or something I like
our cooldown bro you doing the next day
exactly wait to the next day and I wanna
reset you know I'm saying and and that
was what saved me because I didn't know
that I got some
he was spending up to our buddy got
looked about you know a thousand I'm
like property oh my god no no yeah it's
not worth you don't even need to infuse
anything right now
whoa whoa well here's the thing for me
personally and I know a lot of my clan
mates are like this Lieber was very
sleeper crimson those are the two that
seemed to be like y'all we're not
leaving or whispering right sleeper
whisper cringing those are the POS or
escalation arm shot shotgun yeah we move
and those were the two for me was
escalation protocol shocker to be honest
we were way under level turning campaign
and um it was uh it was like very
beneficial during certain Baron fights
and then I which I want to ask you now
cuz I've been talking too much
what about you now your experience and
then I want to ask you specifically
about the barons and themselves like how
did you like that bad boy like what was
going on I actually really enjoyed each
one of those heads up so I did about
three with a friend mm-hmm he was a
little lower than I was where he played
for a minute but by the time I finished
the campaign and the Barons night was
underleveled and I was so low in that
stuff so I did three with a friend
I did five I did the last five or six on
my own that last mission at 460 I dated
at 4:43
was rough I well played it the second
time with my friends and they were like
they had like leveled up and they were
finished in the last minute mission it
like 490 they just smacked them all
around real fast like this isn't even
the same damn game yo chat because we
had the same thing where like we were
underleveled had no business really
being there and it's like shout out to
the new dorm blade was so class oh man I
was on a missile so I gotta say though
Oh get back no look at the supers in a
little bit but like I remember he's
doing those you know that that blessing
that Ward of whatever it's called and um
it was just you know kind of save the
day with certain things having clutch
moments you know my boy dizzy he had his
you know jack
the dog did oh come he got me whatever
really from a distance nothing works
just oh I was so jelly watching I'm like
damn I gotta unlock that serious and
then I had addict he was on doing
torpedo that was it with the Titan and
yeah and I had him he was doing like him
and dizzy would off it my role was to
keep him alive keep giving them
blessings that is actually something
this game has been sorely lacking a
support class like have a purpose that
isn't just shoot stuff in the face reach
so and that's the other piece my brother
he actually went sent know what that
shield dude that thing is a walking like
melting tank thing have you seen that
yes oh my god my brother just like walks
forward and as just people are running
through it's just like orbs are shooting
out of his head constantly he's got like
20 guys running at this like giant
shield you could probably go four wide
around the things yes get a damage buff
room it's a beast like I was like I
don't know if it's gonna be big no that
thing's huge - it's a huge window it's a
big window box that did box and then I
believe like when you shoot through it
you get extra damage did you get X Y as
well as arm generate orbs for the for
the Titan right now he was making enough
orbs on his own I didn't even get to do
anything so Wow when you shoot for my
understanding again I made it wrong he
was just running around with a giant
shield just melting enemies he walked
there I didn't even shoot through it
hardly Wow Wow
okay okay now you talk about the Captain
Michael well he's got it up and then you
can shoot that's like you know eight
Guardians big for their shield that he
acts rotate yes walks with that one and
stuff what runs into it yes it just
melts them right there you can use that
as often so just push forward with that
thing Wow nice like did not know that
oh yeah that's like a monster and
offense and I was like what is happening
right now he's like dude this is fun I
just like run forward and stuff guys I
was like oh no that was like a huge like
you can stand still or if you want to go
push up on a point oh you're gonna push
up on a point
No yeah so no that one knows the add a
bigger surprise than honestly thought
that's that yeah that's nice
that's nice Wow well I guess we're
talking about supers I love my little
mini fist of havoc all the time my
Bailey slams I think is amazing for what
I can aim it if you get up high you
cover some damn distance round but man
that missile blast radius I just
literally played one crucible match my
daily for today
I hit four and that thing is a massive
like you're not gonna escape that if
they're you it's done shouting so I was
somebody on Twitter they had like some
mean snipe of a torpedo Titan that light
was coming at them oh yes yeah he's like
I'd nearly poop my pants
yes guns the super finally the hunters
have a shutdown super like do not be
around them they fire you're kind of
done you in their vision yes it's like a
faster Nova bomb oh it's great in army
also it's super powerful oh my god 20
like a boat lifts a lot of knives isn't
that good credit direct it and do some
stuff I think like the way you twist in
the air my boy sinister was running it
and yeah man that that is very
impressive um what else oh I just got
the the stormcaller one I just got I
just unlocked it when I got to the
second city and yeah I'm just it is
really powerful
it's rich now the only thing is I gotta
figure this out maybe dizzy can help me
or somebody like from what I was told
you cut it off in me super and you have
super and you know what I'm noticing
when I do it doesn't seem like it goes
back yeah I don't know if that's working
as intended or a little bug but I
thought the exact same thing and then I
heard like you don't get it back or if
you turn it on and turn off you might
have a quarter but it's not like hey you
have and this thing right so like I
think from what I remember them saying
see they're like oh yeah you can cut it
off like if you melt a medium in me that
way you can use it more frequently but
it doesn't seem to be working that
yeah maybe maybe something okay because
I thought I was bugging out on that
because that was something I was really
that that kind of a flexibility I want
to look at but I want to go back to you
like I said you were talking with the
bounder barons like tell me like which
one stood out to you
any particular fight just the mechanics
and in how you felt also during these
fights trickster I see I liked because
I'd heard one thing and somebody little
beat it was like first time you call it
first time you play that missions just
like like everybody said they do tried
it they're like oh yeah I died from like
trap or whatever it was like being the
different traps in there are really cool
I saw the little like secret stuff in
that place too from I think she had an
unknown player or hound ish those guys
have been just on fire those guys put
out more content that I don't even know
how to like the little tweaks in there
for me as a solo fight yeah the sniper
was really really cool I love my game
because he was all over that damn level
in places I did not expect to see him
that I really liked because he was all
over the place and then he had the
Holograms looking skills yeah yes gotta
say shout out to the machinist oh yeah
big boy yeah shiness was good I liked
that one his scale I liked the scale of
size on some of these two they're not
small they're though they made like
eight new bosses like legit stuff and
then I was gonna say the final one for
me was a hell of a fight because I was
by myself blue circle on the ground and
had it run around had everything shootin
out he was trying to pick stuff off from
a side yeah yeah so most of them are
really cool
I'm trying to think on the writer wasn't
bad it was cool it's nice to see the
tech back for a little bit yeah it was
my favorite 2d I'd be one of my faves to
this because he had he um but my boy
attic he's like yo I got an exotic and
I'm like no
[Laughter]
Phenix bliss
yo we died laughing what I said was we
attic dizzy we bust out loud it was so
funny and he had like the fake glimmer
all over the plate like that was very
unique I did thought that was hilarious
yeah I mean like shout out to like
themes of things and sometimes Bungie
nails it like I mean like Kuroda was
meant to be like the hive animalistic
rate and it was like the trickster
there's a secret chest with nothing in
it
yes that was literally like trick sir
it's like well you literally can't
believe anything in here okay good
didn't like that was I just followed
through with the theme so like so my
favorite honestly uh for feel wouldn't
happened the first time mm-hmm
you got a guess do we see um your
favorite baron favorite but I was like
definitely like stop like stop me in my
tracks like okay that just happened
Mindbender
try to remember my magnet now refreshing
you go you flip you go ascendant oh yes
yes I'm buggin
I forgot we flew through that that one
was cool
yeah yeah yep definitely never I forgot
about that was cool
yes with the ascendant stuff you were
going back and forth yeah very cool
fight very cool foul shadow zero so shut
up to the rider yeah right right it was
fun it was different like you know you
had your little vehicles stuff like that
um oh no you know what I got a shout out
who's the big boy to mail a boy the one
with the thing I forgot hangman yes
because again attics in there he's
talking crazy you know we don't tell all
these bearings you know we are magic aid
and we gonna go for a hangman cuz
remember was cool about it is you get to
pick which order you get him right so we
did I think we did hangman or whatever
and um you know again we're still kind
of under level we just went straight
campaign really do any type of grinding
anything home straight campaign that was
honestly the way to do it doing like for
anybody who wanted a level sure you
might get a little more but honestly
like ya going toward the campaign these
are the days oh geez yeah
I did shot yo bro because it was so
funny so we get trapping us a rooster in
attic with what I call a one-hitter
quitter is well it's just one hit and
that's it so everybody's like it was
just funny because we were so in the
level we're getting one hit rezzing the
other one and it just kind of scrambling
around the room so I thought the hangman
fight was for Braddock made it funny and
I kept targeting Atticus almost like the
game heard what he said
so we had like this inside joke we just
laugh and it's so funny but that one
definitely tricks the the last one
machinist was because was kind of epic
and scale like you said was big and dumb
big big big and I thought it was a
female Kenshin there was not like I
swear we have more Harder's when they're
like oh she is those like really there's
a lot of what that obviously the last
one mind bender mind bender was near the
end towards the high and one who wasn't
acting no that one's the phonetic the
phonetic mechanic where you know the
Poland oh man yeah that one's trippy
when that were trippy so honestly that's
like so how many I'm bid trying to think
how many total missions are in this damn
campaign can't but yeah it's it's a lot
man it's not like because I mean I would
count on every adventure as a mission
per se the campaign absolutely I would
say at least 10 maybe 11 I'm trying to
think yeah cuz I would say you've got
the K build-up right so you would say
that what other than prison probably is
it the one where you see each Baron
right and then each and then kind of the
last one is a gigantic Lea long mission
with everything I'd say ten or eleven
somewhere there hold all will say
there's one thing I gotta say that's
absolutely hilarious
all right my favorite enemy though it
all of this D is Devane who that runs
the nightclub but I've literally walked
into that loss sector for the first time
and I was like wait a minute are we
gonna fall a night club beats why they
got those beats music my brother would
have been changed the tunes I'm dead I
was like you again it was just classic
bungee like it was just so many not so
many little touches so many Lum bows
right now I didn't think they would be
is I'm actually loving nosy to have you
and you messed around with bows too much
you can't get into him no actually like
mine's not that high level I grab an
infusion just cuz I was waiting but
while I was using it for a while dude
super accurate aim assist is super high
yeah I mean and I shout the Fonz he's
got our sick role with um what you call
with rampage on his and I'm just like do
it's a machine like I didn't think like
boses Loki like part of the matter like
seriously it bows are part of the meta
man not only is off the charts but yeah
yeah he was this is sick you know and it
one shot if you get caught and I've been
getting killed by bows in crucible it's
it's it's definitely definitely a great
new weapon tight man so yeah man so that
was for me was that and then um no she
came and got that and again we're gonna
keep this as spoiler free as possible as
we can but all I would say is I implore
all who listening I implore all who pick
up the DLC do what you got to do to get
to the campaign because we'll get we'll
talk I'll let you talk Aldrin
but I want to talk post Aldrin good
evening City man is that one of the most
beautifulest skyboxes in destiny history
that is some old Lord of the Rings Toki
and joint going on over there
right it's epic it's just man I I cannot
even when they were talking
envy rocks and stuff prior and you saw a
little bit okay that looks cool that's
cool you know sad until you get there
and it's way bigger than that map that's
shown there's more stuff it is truly a
space its own space and honestly the way
it look like I hope they do this for
every kind of you know I mean like I
like putting a bar I like I mean
whatever September is next year then
that's a big bar absolute like man this
needs to be the new thing because it
just felt it for the first time like
destiny felt really like an MMO to me I
was like yo when going somewhere
different it's completely different it's
huge in scope it's part of the in-game
and then as we know this this space will
change and I just never forget going
inside there and then doing you know the
activity we'll talk about later
and um man I cannot say enough about the
Dreaming city please get the campaign
done if you haven't gotten get it done
because that's when the game really
begins that's all I got to say but you
said what you got to say about that and
also on Aldrin which order I mean no
dreaming city I haven't explored it that
much because I was like replaying half
that like the last three missions with
my friends last night I've worked the
last two nights so I haven't had as much
time to just like basically straight IV
this game like you have yes but I mean
so far just like you'll and it's just
just to drive up the opening that was
cool so I mean my experience is limited
I didn't get to experience my first
attempt at that public event mm-hmm
that's crazy it is insane but a little
exploring around at the bounties and
just the stuff I've seen in a couple
blips from videos mm-hmm like it looks
crazy
plus whatever comes later which we'll
talk about in a little bit but overall I
don't even surf is of that place at all
so I mean I got a defer to you on that
one but from what I've seen looks
amazing and I love how when I went there
I got my butt whooped yes that was my
favorite part
preach I got there and I got and I got
killed of like what wait hold it what's
all yes 35 I was like okay this is yeah
straight up you know we're just getting
started
exact and what I love is they now have
sections to say like yo fam you're not
ready you're not ready to be here I love
when I see immune again like of certain
things
oh man even just the the wanted would
spar the wanted barons and stuff I mean
the wanted escapees from the prison from
health and I they take a while to kill
and on top of that I love that they're
everywhere throughout the game like I
was doing you know strikes different
things law sectors you'll see these
wanted you know escapees all over it yes
this powerful man yes super powerful but
on nothing I want to ask you about is I
had a good discussion with a like look
how about so about this and he
approaches dancing different not that
he's not a hardcore he is he is now he
plays all the time we always teased him
like said : what to destiny cash he gets
mad like I said but you know Superman
but he really commits man he plays every
day he's he's out of that so the thing
we've had this discussion is actually
you know from his standpoint he's coming
from true MMO sensibilities gear sets
mid maxing yeah yeah yeah right so his
thing is like yo I love he he was raving
about the collections there it was like
this what I'm talking about see I don't
have to go to the tower
everything is here it so this is
streamlined you know knows and like he's
going on and on about the UI the
bounties the claiming the grabbing the
shade is grabbing the weapons anything
straight from space or whenever you are
so like what do you feel about that in
reference to you know design change and
and UI interface like how would you how
were you feeling when you're getting
into that okay first I'll be honest I
haven't looked at the triumphs in the
collection that much because I've been
trying to play more than beginning to
like lore and click on buttons or
any function time right now but with
regards to all of that like that's great
I mean you're one stuff you're probably
not gonna use that much but way to look
at collections way to give you a task of
hey this is something you can go do I
kind of wish it would didn't have the
name on some of the stuff or like yeah I
never give away I wish it was like
here's a question mark you can get this
kind of here like a little more
vagueness to some of those pieces
because I look goes like oh that's a new
exotic way I already see it okay mm-hmm
I wish some of that stuff wasn't there
no I agree no I agree with you yeah I
didn't like that we was seeing stuff
that we didn't have and I wish those who
question walks yeah I agree but for me
probably one of my biggest things with
regards to MMO feel not whole but feel
talk to me
Armour perks oh my god I was thinking
about like my first piece of armor was
like we have void Ark or solar damage
resistance masterwork levels of like
what's us that was cool but like all the
armor perks are from definitely one I
think everyone is back and then some
eggs so I'm still trying to figure out
the difference between and I'm gonna
actually pull up dim on my computer
while we're talking so there's one that
says like reserves and it says get bonus
reserves and the other one that says you
like have more ammo and I'm like what
the hell is the difference I still
haven't tested that one yet because I
don't know what the two mean but like
all those little things like every roll
I can pull this one I've got rocket
launch reserves increase the amount of
rocket Liam once your ammo you can carry
okay that makes sense but then there's
other ones that's like rocket launch or
scavenger rocket let's just get bonus
reserves when you pick up ammo I don't
know the difference between those two
alright go that's that's old-school d1
let me tell you - let me break it down
remember the daddy's is remember when
used to wear those boots that would give
you extra heavy ammo so let's just say
your rocket normally only held six now
you can go up to eight you don't I mean
based on you know that reserve per day
oughta move because different so on the
on the helmet says Rock
launcher reserves increase the amount of
ammo you can carry that exactly what you
said right but then on my gullets I've
got hold I'm trying to find the one with
it
it says rocket launcher scavenger now
rocket launcher reserves
get bonus reserves when you're picking
up ammo so when you pick up ammo do you
get extra when you pick it up now is
that the thing you want right zero yes
you give reserves to give more
scavengers to get more per brick okay
got it reserves more per brick and then
it's got and then the other ones hold
mark yeah like your bag the other one is
this hole more in the bag and I'm saying
like I mean the amount of pills yeah
zero thank you I just hadn't tested that
one but that makes perfect sense i'm
just apparently like trust me i was over
what i didn't think they would go that
deep but you've got like unflinching for
like every different ammo type like on
your chest you've got and a lot of
actually pretty make sense so you've got
reload speed you've got the grenade
throw distance on the arms I love
Heather got like momentum transfer stuff
that helps the supers marks have mods
like invigoration like I was waiting for
I was like where's my stuff when I pick
up orbs that's back I was like so many
and like and then between all your like
damage types like 2 3 4 5 different
things I'm like that was my biggest win
now I still hate that stats kind of suck
but overall I love the fact that armor
has so much different stuff going on let
me tell you when I from the Dreaming
city that's really kind of trippy I got
one of those - yeah really risk/reward
where you do more damage but but you
receive whatever it that's gonna be
interesting on the one that really like
I've got so many cuz like listen listen
my build I'll be oxide everything I
playing with everything new but in order
to get to the heart content I had to go
old-school d2 which was escalation
protocol shotgun and if you sleep I'm
sorry sleepers coming week every I don't
care how many cores I'm paying spot it
I'm in business with you bro don't do it
all the time I do it in like 30 light
level jumps 30 to 40 light level jumps
all right become 30 40 light levels now
like you know when I'm fight when I was
like 4 30
okay boom you know you know got the 480
or whatever whatever boom 500 boom
so those been the - so what's been
really cool is I've got certain armor
that I don't like I don't want to level
up all the way or dismantle because one
of them has like shotgun kills give
super energy and it's substantial with
escalation protocol think about that
they're not gone yeah helmet that gives
me like linear fusing rifle because mom
asleep is considered linear fusion yep
so it like this one it gives me you know
snap accuracy fast draw it's like one
perk that does all three of those things
right yeah that's like a then I got a
pair of boots
that's like linear fusion rifle reserves
you know they did I got another like arm
is like shotgun reload faster
so I'm like this is the mid maxing in
the building and just a customization
towards this specific loadout that I'm
running with I'm like damn it's hard cuz
I water infuse I want to go up and like
fast but it's like like they would leave
these behind so it's just so funny like
you have to make now those decisions
again we miss this one aesthetically
looks good but this ugly piece of gear
that guy got way better oh oh I don't
even care about looking right now
haven't even thought about it looks at
all but yeah that perk of like give and
take
like the so many different perks that
I've seen and I love that and the fact
that you're gonna have like it a void
build a solar build arc built on top of
everything else
oh geez brah we go like that that aspect
that minutia is destiny that's what I
was voted to see and I'm so happy for
you because I know this was your biggest
worry they didn't talk okay why the hell
did they not mention any of that stuff
I wasn't like final day one patch stuff
or what cuz like they did not ever bring
up any of they just sent like you know
random roles are coming to weapons on
armor they dial like the combat stream
they delve into like the
/ buds and by the way mom's actually
yeah I got a big butt like a mascot
every day like I gotta make sure I get
them oh I've been nice and I got one for
weapons that song does more damage to
powerful enemies I got um I think I
might throw a didn't know I can't do an
escalation because it can only be all it
could only be the newer weapons that's
what I found out oh let me give you guys
some pro tips uh-huh shot the Fonz with
infusion because we know infusion is
crazy out here in these streets master
cause is real better better hold on to
the best I'll tell ya right now a web is
playing hold on to your master cords do
not be infusing every five minutes like
me you know they do be smart but I would
say pro tip if you get the same exact
gun to better devils right one roll has
another better roll whatever the one you
want you want to infuse it you can
infuse it for the same gun type for the
same gun exact gun for just glimmer
cause no matter what course or no last
little shards found that out also
exotics you can use those without you
can use those for infusion let's say for
example I had a um they gave me my first
one was like a risk runner a new risk
runner at like what five old five right
and I had um I believe I had another I
think it was escalation protocol shotgun
and I'm like Tim let me just see if I
can fuse being that they're both in the
same energy slot if I can infuse it it's
gonna ask the course and being that the
exotic is excited it does not require a
master core infusion so those are two
tips to kind of trying to sit because
cores are at a premium right now oh yeah
and I'm very curious to see how they
handle this going for that no spider
reset but core sources to get courses
not really non-existent if we're lifting
up a size of spider you know it's very
random and I'm very curious to see how
they handle xur
cuz I think he may end up having course
cuz cause a real like that it for
everything
armor infusion you know gun infusion
it's you know it's real man so pay
attention to and also to make something
a masterwork a tier 2 tier 3 therefore
whatever mass or the higher the mass the
more it is to infuse man that's tough
expensive [ __ ] are real out here in
these streets please save your course
that Dave Chappelle me you guys you guys
got any more of those course yeah like
and for some who did like play that much
I'd saved up to decent amount so I have
sums but they're gonna go quick when I
finally finally do it but if you have
any saved right now what what drops yes
cuz you're gonna be out here with the
blue garb looking very tangled sure
you're ten good sure ensemble not
looking very hot Guardian not gonna be
flashy
cuz he's gotta put on whatever is the
highest level and I literally had to
adopt that strategy and I thought it was
an interesting design choice I think
they kind of wanna slow down just super
power leveling um also want to ask you
about which we haven't touched at all
damp it now that the full gambit is out
in the wild like uh what do you woody
what are you feeling you know how you
experiencing you haven't touched it at
all since I'm played a few matches I did
the daily whatever day was Wednesday
yesterday I did my daily there I had
probably one of my best matches of all
because for one nobody had sleeper not
even why didn't play with the groups who
were running that way which was lucky to
not play with them and all the crazy
people in PC were just leveling up but I
had one our prime mules were out fur I
don't feel like they had to have tweaked
something mmm first they patched because
that prime evil was out a lot longer now
maybe we weren't as powerful maybe it
had some more health or maybe we're just
like less optimized it's very possible
because like sleepers may still melt but
we had a player we like it got pretty
low and then somebody went innovated got
a pretty big boost and we was back and
forth like multiple times trial it was
like invade once it like it melted so
fast I saw people like you know arrow or
one guy I like a two minute match round
they went full efficiency full melt done
like so I don't know if it's like you
know not everybody was completely
optimized the you know infusion wasn't
having people not run all supers all the
time like
but the one I play that was the I don't
even know what map it is the widgets
just tell me what enemy type was on it
if you could remember I was on it I know
oh I hate that one
like platforming ball damn Shriekers
that not all Blake I know I actually
didn't have any strikers on mine
- recurs in there brutal they all got
shot by the Shriekers trying to deposit
moulds back through the dam jumping and
I'm warlock floof and all over the place
getting shot up oh man I was I didn't
have a good I mean I was like what it
was like it was a completely different
enemy types Oh Thrones were like a lot
quicker to kill curse they're all Duke
do kind of their own thing they're gonna
explode so run by let them pop and you
get some you know some quicker stuff but
then you have things like Knights that
will take a little bit longer but that
map was like you had the little that one
was easier to get around because you
little like launched pods that was shoot
your awesome app and the other one I
feel like the forest one sometimes if
you're on one side you gotta run
anything like cheese's this is a long
walk across like sometimes that felt
like it was too far where you really got
to be like okay you to start doing that
we're gonna start across like facts that
was more important there the other one
were like okay we're killing stuff here
okay we're going to the other side
launch were there so that was almost a
little more in the mix quicker and then
as it was different tiers and levels it
seemed to not be just this flight this
flat forest so yeah the invaders seem to
have more issues yes the ones who came
in we're having success it seemed on
both sides absolutely yeah man and hold
on should all 0 see I was gonna get to
is there he talking about what I think
about the blind well on mechanical
harmony um D obviously you've not
touched that yet right alright so um
yeah I'll jump in I'm not gonna listen
alright so let's start from the
experience I think it's fantastic it is
chaotic
you are literally in oh well but it's
like first of all the the um the
aesthetics is just this pristine just
think of like a clone think of like a
beautiful glass castle and you're inside
and like I said you're in this thing you
kind of set off this
thing to charge up the well or whatever
it is and at that point the scorn start
coming in like wildfire and um it's
insane because as you know this way new
enemy types we didn't go too deep but
the new enemy types they all behave
different right so we have those
aggressive guys with the chains you know
and they got these other ones but they
like the little tiki torches they're
very fanatical you know and then you got
those little the new arm
they almost remind me of the resident
evil crawlers or whatever on the floor
but they extinct they explode also like
exploding crawl and they're very yeah
and they're very fast and because you're
in this confined space yeah you can't
really get away so it's really good a
lot if you have defensive subclasses you
know the Warlock was shining in there
you know that is gonna say the people
who have oh you don't have the Warlock
build you're gonna level that thing up
for the raid because it's gonna be I'm
so glad I made that my first choice for
the raid like I'm going to be ready so
um yeah that one tremendous in there
tightened tremendous in there you want a
hunter with the golden bullet the knives
you know I'm saying doing his thing to
knock out the bosses and they have this
cool mechanic so basically what the best
I can describe it is it's a it's court
of Oryx meets escalation protocol but
better than both because what happens is
as you go from well to well and you
charge up these things then you have to
get into a boss encounter and the boss
encounter is two of them and you cannot
damage these bosses and that's kind of
the theme of the blind well you cannot
damage anything until you get this thing
called harmony and there's certain
enemies you could see that have it
there's they glow when you get it then
when you have harmony it's like a
ten-second time or whatever it is once
you get that timer then it's like you
have to go full tilt and it will do
damage to break the shields but it still
takes a long time and it has to be a
coordinated effort and a concentrated
effort because there's also a timer
involved right and oh it's just so many
other things also here you have to stay
in the well a lot of those guys that
have the enemies that have the Harmony
are outside of the world
you have to go out when you go outside
of the well you lose kind of like a
protection and you got a timer to get
back in otherwise you'll die it's like
it's almost like a marching master don't
don't don't it's warning you get back in
so all all all I want to say is with all
of this
the mode is fantastic but it just mean
adequate are we like yo if they're doing
this for this just mold right can you
imagine what the rate and again you
haven't seen it last wish but I'm just
gonna tell you right now I got a lot of
confidence from this rate might be
something special man like we'll see
Valter glass is always going to vote the
class here's that take a king auryx is
gonna like this oh she's got a feeling
man I got it from a couple videos and a
couple like data mine pieces if there's
as many encounters as I think there
might be alone much less like what all
is gonna be in there and secrets and all
that fun stuff
dude yeah like no I mean from everything
I've seen so far the bar set really
really high expectations they're like
blown away and then on top of whatever
the raid team is always able to shout
out to Joker off on Twitter Bungie
putting in the word absolute but man
like select King more bosses than ever
and we've had four through last night's
cuz we had war priest golgoroth
daughters and then Oryx that's war so
more has to be five mm-hmm and then
whatever else crazy something either
jumping puzzle or wall of thunder or is
gonna happen there is a puzzle one of my
clan mates peeked into the triumph I
didn't but he peeked into the tribes
because you know again Loki these tribes
and collections are small in certain
things I didn't yeah I didn't do it I'm
not all I'm gonna all I would say
they're supposedly maybe one different
mechanic other than chess boss fight in
this right yeah that's what I thought I
saw six pieces and one of them was like
I think some something that didn't sound
like defeat exactly exactly exactly yeah
that's what we got to look to look
forward to but
overall man I mean this this is the army
again it's early I want to reserve
judgment until the raid does come but in
my opinion I'm confident enough to say
this feels like the taken King moment
it's funny heals like yo we're back
we're back all the way we've got
everything you want and um it's just so
much to do it is just so much to do he's
like I look at all the bounties now and
all the things and I'm overwhelmed I'm
like okay what am I gonna do now what
I'm gonna do today
okay can I work on this cake where can I
get this all right no you know what the
cruise was really poppin right now
oh but then again I got my clan stuff to
do and that requires you to work with a
clan and get powerful gear so this so is
different sources and the game kind of
guides you it gives you the freedom
right to say hey you know do it this way
do it that way you know the man you look
at the map you know strikes are on the
map again you're like oh man this is
cool like it's just so much little
things
coupled with how great the game let's go
then I got a shout out we're gonna we're
gonna get into the twelve the music oh
can we give destinies do with music
finally game I mean I'm pretty sure we
always they're over Lake but I feel like
because of the stigma with destiny
sometimes that it really doesn't get
enough credit like I'm I gotta throw the
gauntlet down ain't no game with better
I'm talking about no disrespect to Marty
O'Donnell right cuz his des Spears
fantastic but I got a low-key keep it
real since taken King since um rise of
iron has some iconic beams
I remember the raid I could sing the
raid music to you right now does that HD
like stop there
and you fighting the boss the Cable Guy
no that's like they've got iconic scenes
and then the cane star very emotional
you know that music when you go back to
the tower bro crazy now I like the sound
like and they've kind of tweaked the
sound up they always do this
occasionally like tweaking the sounds on
all the guns things just sound a little
different little like a little refine
here a little tweak there but always the
soundtrack as you're going through know
every like always awesome I'm putting it
out there I'll put the calling down best
music in gaming I'm sorry I was like I'm
trying to think what I would have played
like I honestly would have to listen to
God of War in the moment that might be
my only one that fits because of story
and feel and a couple moments in there
but I mean there it's if it isn't if it
is or isn't better I'm trying to like
remember like for what I remember like
destiny still is just like it nailed all
of it it's another love and then they
got the Gregorian chants and then for
the people my boy hit me the babies I
well maybe halo since I mean from the
beginning yes halo one the iconic thing
we know nuns taught you that I respect
that but it's just like I'm talking
about from a consistent sequel and
constant iteration
oh shut out to zero whisper music yes
yes you know I'm saying like it just
like bro they'd know how to get think
like even cursive Oh sounds as bad as
that DLC was you know when you fly oh
come on bro when you fly you hit that is
crazy
I was listed to Osiris team I was listen
to us some warm and stuff and we're
gonna combine that soundtrack fam they
got it just do the killer for free yeah
buddy rewards I'll finish the campaign
yeah I'll finish the money but anyway
I've wanted one on my tangent yo
shout-out to
and be FJ and shadow selves ad as
whatever clan makes he's in there good
to see you yeah man
so what I'll let you talk we talk a lot
but no man just let you near the road
like any you've been in a bit more
played a lot but not as much as you so
yeah yeah she said listen to the
warframe sound sure I feel you zero but
the problem I have with any other game
in comparison is again body of work I'm
not dissing offering I've not listen to
everything ever there's something but
again I can name you like at least 12 to
15 tracks from destiny that is just
consistent bangers from start to finish
and I'm excluding I'm not even playing
for it but I could throw in d1 and and
marty with the spheres and get y'all out
of here I'm being nice and excluding
that right cuz Marty got his own
situation going on and out of respect
for him I'm not gonna include that I'm
gonna go from taking King on every DLC
there's at least five iconic soundtracks
or tracks that when you hear it mentally
you know what you were doing you know
what was going on he remember the remix
for the suffix prime strike that was
like a little twinge of like the recent
do man did that's me with like the rock
like oh that one was that was like a
proper remix that fit that one really
well I always like no I don't want to
hear it up some being ignorant they're
not given my gay listen you can't you
may not like the game if it's a grinding
is to grind it for you you feel they're
ripping you off that's your business
I get that but if you want put music to
music bro it's no it's no comparison
they got symphonies going on doing stuff
in here that I'm just like this they
understand tone they understand feeling
they understand what it is you know I'm
saying nah fam 0 warfare makes seeing it
I'm sorry I'm shutting your mic off it's
not seeing it I'm gonna give you 10
tracks and we're gonna go blow for blow
it's not seeing it
no way no how period but
down ranting I'm not trying to hear it
I'm not trying to hear it because at the
end of the day they they are not giving
this game credit for what it's doing
well and that is undisputed continue I
don't even know where we're going off on
it a pipe music and sound and good-bye
the weakest right play Osiris DLC music
he's out of it what when you flew it
it's over it's all the panopticon which
we got to see more of a knock you looked
really cool yep
so I'm trying to think so what else from
forsaken itself without going so like I
mean gambit the few matches I've done
are fun but that's just a huge different
pillar like all I want to log into
destiny what I want to just go play some
game it for a little that's like gonna
just be another thing I'll work on
leveling up crucible I got some practice
to do felt really bad at my last match
trying to think what else so nobody's
touched I mean very few people have
touched a nightfall yet but now did you
see you get two different weeklies
regular nightfall and the scouring
nightfall yes yes yes I am NOT ready for
that life so this to try to get me in
here and yeah I actually heard um what
was going on cuz it's like was it like
5:30 or something like that and I'm like
look I don't worry yeah I don't need
that level of frustration for Sagan has
made it very clear when you're in an
area that you're not supposed to be
because you're not of level get out of
here yeah pretty clear like I haven't
seen a whole lot of people touching
those yet I think the highest I've seen
someone who's like 522 which I still not
sure how they got there probably
just no life in it beyond what you have
at that point you have to go like I mean
you hit all the dailies and well if
you're just unlucky what if I get a mark
and I get another mark and that's like a
piece that doesn't upgrade so I mean
some of that's just like having good
some some good roles too but I mean
night falls I do like how you can pick
three that's really cool so you can
grind them out
speaking of nightfall strikes have you
done the two strikes the new ones all
right I'm done the nominee I couldn't
refuse cuz I was told I did one that I
thought was absolutely spectacular it
did so would like Toby was like oh no
that was the PlayStation exclusive
strike that you just knock at like oh so
we're Lord of the PlayStation exclusives
alaikum shadows was the original
PlayStation exclusive that's the all
taken one okay so maybe I did I did a
strike yeah that's the new one that's
not for exclusive that's all I love that
oh my god that strikes amazing that is
so well done ladies talk it out come to
me I was like you've got big mechanics
with like the subway trains that was
amazing like the first time you're like
oh what happened here smash I'm like my
buddy I literally jumped up to the side
my brother was like hey what did he say
just ran right over him I was like oh
good to watch the trains are really cool
I just run on the top of the tracks now
I suppose yeah you can actually get up
there and do that the modifiers like if
you go on a heavy weight day with a good
dude grenade launchers are just real
like great lots of holidays shout-out to
edge transit y'all yeah I get its treads
three of them I got it on the eid easy
man my got Possible's 200
I actually got Genesis and filled prep
weight or they all come in that way it
must call no Genesis I got to I got one
of the rampage and snapshot sites so
that one didn't have Genesis know
Genesis at all
this is a big-time park man for PvE
big-time big-time park
love it man and that this is the beauty
of the granary we're sitting here if I
remember one looks much sort of said oh
you'll be excited about you're like oh I
guess we got a yep
you need some random in there so you got
trains you got an actual prison room
which is fun and that boss dies so fast
with the right modifiers how literally
lit up my entire fire too even got the
first time Oh what's happening Oh God
[Music]
beautiful it's again without spoiling
it's one of the UH the very cool like it
just reminds me of like why I miss
strikes right like you missed cuz this
is one thing we really yes there's one
thing attic brought to my attention he's
like I don't like that they're doing you
know the story missions is you know
whatever whatever and I forgot about
strikes and just you know it just
brought me back to like I'm legal for
the first time but this is so well done
and um yeah man they really what more
can I say I mean it's just again it's
it's a love letter right now you know to
to the hardcore with ways like we've
heard you and then even in fairness to
people who say overall they did we just
bring d1 stuff back and you guys are
crazy it's technically not because at
the end of the day the things that are
d1 that have come back have come back in
better iterations not in the exact same
it's evolved yes
and it's evolved for the better so the
lessons learned from the to have now
shaped you know forsaken and it you know
listen they rather high right now man I
think this is this is probably the
highest I've been for the game you know
and I be honest I got a little emotional
II I got a little motion I played flash
points one through three in the car and
I listened to us hours terrible worried
I'm sure
but we're like pros but the first couple
work just out of sync no wait no doubt
but to be eyes give us credit now we was
we was we were passionate so you can hit
a passion right that hasn't changed
that hasn't changed so at the end of the
days it's like okay you know and I
remember you saying stuff like man
you're like I don't know it did you were
like yo maybe they got away did you know
we were so we were so bothered in a mess
like we were so it was such a dark time
and it just and I could hear in my voice
like oh I don't think so I don't I don't
think they could do it like this
this is arguably like they've done it
twice now
like one of the greatest comebacks in
gaming it's close to being completed
twice because the first one was
obviously d1 was started off but it
started off with it got better and then
you know 10 King I mean then it kind of
hit a real content route part I think
that was the issue one more so it hit
the content drought wall all the games
came out boom then taken King comes back
saves a day yada yada yada this is they
shot their own self in the foot right
took away everything that the community
loved then on top of that is way more
things to play the competitive MMO space
console shooter space has dammit you
know tripled and we're like well I heard
us say you know what month should they
do it should they call I remember saying
stuff like oh yeah like when do you put
it what are you going up against what
are you gonna fight you got we got all
the stuff we figured it was gonna be a
battle to come with him or like what
where where does it fit can they get it
done and I think all three Studios Lee
had hi moon Vicarious Visions I don't
know who I think hi moon was more on
this one but seriously like they put so
much work in made so many changes that I
back then I know I know I didn't think
it could happen so and the fact that I'm
in this state now
dude I'm blown away hats off to Bungie
like seriously they didn't alert salute
as much as we've given them crap as much
as they've taken crap and they had to
eat they had to take it because the game
was in such a terrible place and I know
people that still say hey I'm not there
yet still I hear you guys without
whatever I may give it a week or two but
the fact that they're even considering
to me speaks volumes that the change is
significant for them to even consider so
listen you know the sky's limit just got
they got to keep on pushing you know and
I'm excited I'm excited for the future
as long as this now it's the new
standard moving forward we would not go
away we would not deviate we would not
try to cater to other bases do what you
do best and last thing I'll say to is I
said this before I was on a brat podcast
is that um I was actually impressed but
the number of cinematics in this
expansion mm-hmm
because remember means you again
listening the old flash budget we talk
when we say yo we've heard the direction
that they're switching to you know kind
of just more giving hardcore stuff in
hardcore grind but less in a macron we
heard that before that they would be
changing their philosophy and the thing
is to still see that not again I know
this is the big expansion we'll see how
that applies shout out to my boy Gaming
Forte you know he said that um you know
he wants a seat he doesn't expect that
to continue with the black armory
chokers route or penumbra because those
are technically like Rea layers
expansion and smaller expansions but I'm
just curious you know I'm saying because
you know forsaken I didn't expect this
amount I mean we got sequence after
sequence of a sequence it almost felt a
little red Moorish because you'd see the
little logo of forsaken come in and come
out remember like our red war we do with
a what goal so um yeah I'm the rammer
from talk too much yeah you go ahead man
you guys look wait what do you feel
overall when I was getting says twelve
uh
I mean this is like ten steps forward
one sidestep like for me there's so many
things they did right yeah
the feel of the tingle Shore the
openness of the region's like the feel
of the scorn a whole new enemy race that
literally doesn't feel like even take
and didn't quite have I mean they are
kind their note they're somewhat
different but they still didn't have a
vast difference like this is new even
the abomination is not just an odor ogre
it is its own thing you've got the
lantern guys those guys are really when
they start swinging
good luck hittin that damn lantern
you're kind of screwed the scree we're
terrifying so I mean the enemy type is
cool we've got two new spaces but you
can use your Sparrow on both thank God I
was gonna so I was like oh please let me
and there was a one-note Osiris us the
cold pull that crap the rolls the armor
the activities to do
gambit like being a third pillar just
the respect of like hey there's three
different night falls if you want to do
it you don't get stuck doing one just
the selection of the story missions if
you want to go do the strikes like the
way the campaign progressed and then
needing to do things to move on I think
they need a couple pointers for people
who really are like kind of relatively
new jumping in yes yes might be in limbo
too
they might need a bit of guidance too
like gets to the next phase otherwise
they might be like is is this kind of it
like where do you go next yeah yeah so
there may need to be a couple of those
pieces but overall I haven't even done
the third strike on the Dreaming city
yet I don't even know what that's gonna
be like mm-hmm the secrets that I've
seen in little videos I mean there's the
places of stuff to find the jumping
puzzles were gonna be doing my brothers
gonna hate every one of them he just
hates jumping in general so even if it's
on a Titan but yeah yeah warlock
flooping flooping this rough
quick question have you gotten okay we
got it it's one thing I forgot we got to
talk about there's a bazillion things we
haven't touched but yeah go ahead I
noticed I don't know if this is that uh
three of coins were removed from the
inventory have gone I don't it's a play
and I've played a ton of hours I've only
gotten one exotic I don't even think
I've got one yep I got risk rudder
that's all I got right I've got zero so
far exactly I've spoken to all my clan
mates and the only person that has
anything somebody has Queens breakers
bro yes I don't know if that's a quest I
was someone of my clan make shout out
the tag he's got Queen breakers bow and
I believe one other person I think um
shout out Gary to chat or 70 on one of
the clam meat has another arm exact but
it's lit out that's literally me
counting like two people right so as a
result how do you know this is a big
subject matter for us I won't know how
you feel about that are they are exotics
rare and actually really cool and hard
to get yeah then I'm fine with it we
already have way too many from d1 that
you can mess with those and as you
occasionally be like holy crap I got a
new exotic that's actually gonna be a
feeling again exact
now if surd goes and screws the pooch
then I'm gonna be pissed but for this
week I've enjoyed it exactly I guess my
only thing my question is I'm very
curious now to see Houser is handle
because I think that was the right call
and because legendaries are so good now
you don't not even thinking about
anymore because it'll random roles I
mean you're like oh you haven't gotten
one but you know saying like it's not as
you're not just showering us anymore
you know they didn't feel they were just
like what's another weapon I'm gonna use
it's just unlimited and how many slots I
can put it in they did it that way and I
miss that so much and it's just the fact
that you're saying you haven't I haven't
seen it I know people have been doing
reviews but they're probably like every
content creators like if you have one
send me an email or linkers
you might get one late all the powerful
gear yeah so yeah and it would be really
cool if the raid has like the one chest
that does have a chance at exotics like
there's more incentive to do that again
because you're gonna be struggling so oh
sháá zero North I figure he's like oh my
god argue that exotics should be hidden
behind quest instead of the place and
they are you still have the ace of
spades you know we know that's going cuz
you gotta get what you called Katie's
game but malfeasance is game but my
understanding so there's there's still a
couple oh i unlock chaperone quest
I haven't even I don't even know how to
do that yet so yeah Ivan Locke chaperone
I forgot what I did and a man is a man
it's literally the first that was kind
of like get 20 shotgun kills in the
crucible now it's like some you know use
arc and it got that annoying thing it's
like I'm gonna say is it really gonna
kick your butt again yes it's two it's
three times the kicking of the block
because one it's that the the second
part of the bounty has art kills melee
kills you know Solar and defeat in the
crucible loses progress coming up that
are gonna be hard now here's the
question - and this is from my brother
one who's not exactly skilled at
crucible he's happy to play support like
gambit school cuz he doesn't have to go
PvP yes he is really really like beyond
livid that Ace of Spades requires him to
kill people in gambit he'll he'll
invaders aliens yes tough right now I'll
tell you how I did it shut up this what
your brother hasn't had to do he's not
going his teammates will not like this
and that's the run of crimson together
well not evil I mean I mean if you can
get shout out to UM we didn't talk about
any guns we like but um ten paces if he
can get ten paces what a good role and
on what you call it on another yeah what
you call it's got an payload
listen it's tough man I'm shocked that
they tied it
tell him if he thinks that but he said I
mean oh damn it party stuff because you
gotta get five and at first I thought I
had to invade and then get the kills
well let's look at reeds that's the way
absolutely I was like reading in my and
another one of my friends who I know
last night oh no right it's all over
this it's the other way and I was like
it doesn't even read the right way
mmhmm yeah man it's definitely it's like
so now you've got to kill the invaders
so what ended up happening it like AG
would be like a cyclotron we're both go
for it at the same time you see the
invader point amount just how many
direction where we at and both of us go
so basically we're not even doing the
objective anymore we're literally I give
up we're going for these girls one of
whoever get the credit that's how you
know I got it so then the second step is
like where I'm at now it's like 25
precision kills with hand cannons and
again he's in a better place but would
you see these but not bad on PC but
still in a better place but yeah I think
if you're gonna have something that is
like make it a quest like have a then
have a true pvp exotic right make it
like make it separate don't make
something connected to your story and
force you into doing career and that's
one of those like for him I can
understand because it's really early and
he hates crucible because it's just not
his thing like he's happy to support and
other things and he loves his shield and
stuff like that but in general and
that's one of those four I mean what if
people just don't really I mean crucible
is not their thing some people could be
awesome at PB II and if they're awesome
and that's killed a shooting they're
probably gonna be decent but I mean
generally like competitive especially is
like a just a whole different animal all
I would say is this and I feel you guys
are not wrong you know I'm saying I like
these big sometimes only for this damn
point
it forces you I do love crucible and I
am biased in that respect I'm Alan you
know saying but I like sometimes that it
forces me to jump out my comfort zone
like to be honest unless I'm gonna be
honest with you I've played enough game
but I like the mode I love it you know
but it's something that um you I bought
this in zero
talk by text you can listen I get it all
I'm saying is once in a while it's okay
to jump outside your comfort zone try
something different because I knew put
it this way if that part of the first
part I wouldn't been playing gambit a
lot in the beginning of forsaken I know
me I've been doing campaign all that
stuff not even messing with really
crucible and not really messing with cam
but specifically so it kind of fortunate
like damn how really want this gun I
gotta get this you don't say like is it
bad game design yeah you can probably
argue that is it something that's
forcing you to do something that maybe
you don't want to do absolutely
you know saying but if you want that gun
that's the only way you're gonna get it
rough so you got a decision ultimately
we all gonna be in it it's worth it
which is the part where they're gonna
push it but even zeros like you put give
a pre-ordered ornament on something that
makes you do something that not
everybody will and in the crucible zero
you selfish online player offline player
you like soft you're always off play
which then he's playing invisible and
exactly he's invisible that's what this
is the visible people that's talking not
like zeros got a point yes here we got
to have you on one of these two what do
you think have path or hat have Pat day
you're happy okay go there fair that
would be your way to do it how would be
away this or this no you're right zero
absolutely stand corrected you are right
I like that yeah you playing that let me
looking at your daily see and the
dailies okay if you want it like Gopal
and have that as your incentive to go do
it occasionally be like hey you want
some powerful gear you know complete two
crucible matches for the day it doesn't
have to be a lot but it gets you in
there makes you at least do it even if
you're not great you claim you finish on
you know gets a lot in peace in fierce
crucible guys just cut you off for one
second and fantastic if you're gonna do
either or you know 25 with a hair cannon
ain't you know he knows it's gotta be
difficult level they actually yeah okay
okay go kill 10 strike bosses
that's two yeah right like these
to be long and that's fine and my
brother would do that all day like I
left for a wheat like I was doing stuff
where we can came back and they dude had
like level of a whole other character on
his own he will play the crap out of the
game if you give him a way for him to
progress through it
mm-hmm so that is like I mean I'm okay
making a people like you need 25
headshot kills which you know what do
you get
not always headshot kills maybe two or
three a match I mean easy like ten
matches okay ten ten strikes like make
that time some what about I'm totally
fine with that yes they are path be just
so the people who really want to I mean
you can make it extra long on the other
side it's like if it's crucible it's
easier even so there's incentive to push
him into that but if they really
absolutely don't want to then yeah I'm
okay with that
so solutely them eyes and ya know a
couple things actually saw blue Wes low
and I kind of wanted to say go for it he
was saying to he's basically was just
saying he's only issue before shaking
right now is the rewards so I saw some
people do like blind well and like if I
get like one blue or there's certain
things you do we're just if it's not
powerful gear mmm-hmm like you really
seem stuck at 500 so the whole thing
about like doing an activity you're
helping some of you out that you're
supposed to get something at least one
level around then they say like same
level or maybe one level more even if
you go help somebody out
like it doesn't unless it says powerful
is 500 it's alright you're at that soft
cat why don't you get your right again
we gotta be careful no no I know okay so
here's the other 200 tokens for gunsmith
packages when we don't even get a mod in
the package fair I agree with that
master work system he's like is the big
case one step forward one step back very
confusing why we can't just reroll the
master work bonus on our weapons at the
cost of reverting back to level one same
goes for the armor attributes like
you're literally stuck with it whatever
it gets like so you can customize but
the random kind of sticks it like I
don't I don't know why I'm like I'm torn
like it would be cool like the not
re-rolling every perk but your ass work
has nothing you really make the gun
yours mm-hmm and that one's like go
perks and roles like
if you are lucky enough to finally get
your perks then your role isn't right on
your mouth work you like a deal like if
you can't if you can't even random role
I even if it's just like spent in and go
for a random new start over like if
there's no way to go for another it is
kind of a bit frustrating so yeah little
tweaks and these are literally is like
his only things like I mean there's
mommy said nitpicks like I don't
considered the I don't consider these
like the only broken by fusion and
master work little tweaks I mean these
are small stuff but like this is the
point where you know somebody like that
by the way I played a match against blue
Wes low and free gambit was on I got
smoked got worked so bad fruit was on
there snipe in my head off a few times
it's like I just said well I sent blue a
slow message afterwards those just like
dude making it look too easy just
absolutely I always try and be civil in
that stuff just because those guys are
cool but yeah absolutely gets the
problem of PC like the good that's guilt
cat the skill cap in PC is so high God
is it ever yeah it's crazy it's great
listen all that stuff like I said it
like cual your life stuff and those are
like tweaks I don't feel like I mean
they're not wrong I'm just saying like
I'm not like oh my god because this
happened I get to burst you know I'm not
on that like at all
either so it's yeah of course you know
I'm saying like right now it's about
orange Jesus with the armor first of all
let's give credit where credit is due
there's a randomized stuff with the
armor now that is valuable so now we're
like damn I really want a chance to
excuse me like to long roll that and
then you know getting that another
chance to long and you know the perks
you want with the mod you want I get
that I completely get that that'll be
cool so basically they wanting like a d1
gunsmith where for the I'm right amount
you know you can reroll the gym again
maybe that still come time I'm confident
those type of changes will be considered
especially with this new Bungie that
we've been getting you know the last six
months whatever they they've been so
receptive to listening to feedback so
yeah and as far as D blind well on my
experience Tier one you know yeah they
were wasn't yeah they weren't that great
tier two was given out the damn super
cool subclass though yes and what about
after that right right so they need out
but I was getting I was
gaining on random role purple drops but
I I have to admit agree with them that
the arm the light level was still kind
of capped I wasn't getting like anything
over the 500 light level at that point
and tier 3 we tried one it was it was a
joke like we shot Aperol and he said
immune and that was okay we're not ready
for this like yeah we shot one score and
it was like what are you doing yeah Oh
tweaks - nothing I considered
game-breaking I think they will get
addressed I'm confident they will get
address and remember I was one who told
you I was gonna get address told you
told you told you like how much happened
to the old supers though some tweets but
not a lot I will give you that we say
again we are they gonna get revamped it
was like so are you gonna go missile
super you're gonna go fist and have it
I'm gonna go missile every single time
if I'm running that but to be on a year
there's certain ones that are better
because of the clan obviously but if you
look at a hunter right now and if you
look at a warlock right now right and
you look at that damn crimson I mean
it's gonna be crimson they're armed the
solar hunter new one right that one is
super effective where I said you look at
you know you got lost stuff that's super
effective and then you got stuff that
okay yeah as a dorm blade am I really
going into the crucible with that you'd
understand Azzam there's certain ones I
feel that have its place for certain
things and even though the new economy
coming our way thing for arm well it's
cool but it's more PvE I still think
certain ones fit towards certain you
know place that I mean certain
activities as opposed to oh this one is
just better than that one all the way
that's just me but as a Titan maybe you
big to differ because you can't see
yourself using standard striker anymore
you know I kind of get that for you
I'm just saying like for the other
subclasses maybe that's a mistake with
Titan is when I'm crazily trying to say
right yeah but the other stuff like I
feel each class the only class I feel
that I feel is completely useless right
as a warlock is the attunement of sky
dawn blade one that you know you're
jumping in he supposed to have the wings
with that kind of thing I don't think
that's really gonna compete so I think
they have to look at usage right now and
say okay this they got to do something
for this one here so forth Titan which
one do you feel like is completely like
I would not use that no more kind of
thing so hammers is like either hammers
is probably the most even split do you
want range or do you want a really close
smash
we're always have actually different
purposes I could see fist of havoc I
have a mini fist of havoc and I have a
missile right like that and then for
ward of dawn versus you're walking
bubble like I know you can get one now
if you have ward of dawn I could see
having more benefit for something like
blind well potentially of stuff running
in but I mean that giant super wall in
Fernie was also kind of a monster so
like but yeah Titan I will definitely
say missile crushing it I mean zero
Justin Chet literally said new knives
out damage celestial Nighthawk no he was
Golden Gun like that right there
mmm-hmm so yeah that's what was gonna
say so that was my hunch they looked
amazing they sounded amazing and now
they outshine the rest so that was
literally what I said previously in my
bet to you is like are the other ones
are gonna get buffed up to match these
yet not yet because they haven't been
looked at individually but each if
you've played with the old ones which I
have and you haven't you'll notice
they're still more effective because of
the base changes they made to abilities
so now like melee and super so that's
not what I'm talking about I understand
that but that still plays in part of the
subclass because at the end of the day
but what you call it the arm like the
grenade damage and all that stuff still
makes stuff more effective we're not
we're acting like gunslinger did not get
any buffs at all they the extension of
the what you call it um the duration of
the gun the storm the storm trance has
been crazy more damage in PvE so let's
not act like no buff happened to the old
now come on now they you said they were
gonna be no changes and they were just
gonna throw it in and it did happen so
so we're like half and half like so I
got left to the side some got some buffs
but it sounds like like the worms got
buffs like I mean so I guess there are
some have different purposes one's a
giant beam ones like traveling around
and some have different purposes but I
still feel like some outshine and that
will take some balancing it comes down
to new stuff in the sandbox let the
sandbox settle right now after you know
whatever come before was it black
armories necks or whatever's next
you know let's see they'll look at the
usage rates they'll look at okay Wow
nobody taking that one he boss this is
talking alright the strike are you guys
say the basic standing one when they've
taken to a pedo all day Oh game and
Forte what's that baby
so that's they do maybe I'll get you on
you god knows his destiny as well just
like you know they're gonna have to look
at that data and that's where you come
in and then Ivonne says gets his real
old-school subclass super buff redone
Redux you could throw a of my face I was
like yeah if anything we'll just buy
each other a beer or a drink because as
I got say it's probably fairly split
because some needed some but I mean once
he heard zeros like that doesn't apply
to my solar hundred thousand close out
classes gunslinger straight up he's like
they're gonna do my super time oh no
like I just crying oh bring it up
because like my missile that one PvP
smash like did was I was like there were
people and I was like I got four kills I
was like there's no way and radius is
massive on that thing so today and they
did say somebody supers are kind of
break the key it's like good we gotta
let the better settle we know all of us
is game with that play these classes
enough we know that there's certain
classes that are way better and your
priorities are going to change like I
know for me in PvE I'm doing great I'm
doing my the new dorm play super
because it is needed I have saved my
team so much time with that well of
Radiance whatever it's called why I'm
giving out empowering rift and healing
rift at the same time my abilities are
charging and then on top of that this is
exotic that when I get it
if I get kills with in that well in that
bubble I get my super energy back again
like you gaining super so it's gonna be
crazy and difficult level activities
already know what I'm doing that when I
want pure DPS I'm going Dragon Ball Z no
saying if I aim that like that be like
that was the that date that would that
super is the direct anti like the ads of
the storm treads where I was doing
tickle fingers run around a match that
is doing yellow bars just okay we go
into town it's not completely useless or
all I'm just saying is it's better than
what you call the thousand cuts is
better and all and all I was also saying
is there was an extension to Golden Gun
with the buff that they made per kill
for extension is it enough to still
compete with thousand cuts probably not
but that's all I'm saying they got it
they got a look at all the stuff give it
a couple of weeks gave it by next DLC I
must say I'm assuming they will
definitely be that discussion brought up
again about the subclass rankings oh
yeah no we're at timewise right now hour
and a half Bungie didn't have their tois
pretty light but a couple things we did
want to touch on full calendar of year
to case you guys haven't seen it that
whole things in there but they've just
pretty much been sitting back taking
everything in I'm sure taking a thousand
data point notes on their spreadsheets
and analyzing everything and seeing how
things are going and making sure
everything runs flawlessly and honestly
I've had like one or two maybe one or
two kicks but mostly overall very very
stable for a rush
absolutely I haven't heard anything
crazy they said they were gonna beacuse
I don't know if you had them I figured
they'd be worse on console probably
worse on PlayStation with all the damn
three people but PC I was fine log ready
oh yeah forgot about the Freak yeah now
we got to talk about this yes sir oh yes
wish yes
so 914 28 10:10 a.m. Pacific 12 central
1 a.m. Eastern for all you people in the
United States we got a raid coming it's
got a regatta rate coming from oh really
cool - yes potentially gonna get some
legit physical rewards this time showed
out it's a red belt it actually would be
really funny if you actually had to send
it to the next team when you when you
lost six or seven out there in the world
and if you lose you have to send it over
or send it back to Bungie if you lose
it's like a contract or something this
is such a great marketing tool that I am
surprised they never took advantage of
earlier because again we all consider
trades the pinnacle you know I'm saying
like that that is destiny the heart
content you know some of the greatest
content some of the greatest experiences
we've had you know I've met countless
friends that people in rage that I now
consider friends in real life because
he's like you've been through the war
together you've been through Vietnam
together with this person and survived
the most difficult content my boy wrote
oh you know sad then shut them out but
um yeah man it's like this is cool this
is cool I think this is a great touch it
looks dope like I look at it like it
looks that looks like computer rendered
but still it looks like that well no but
it looks like this looks like it's gonna
have leather like ornate design little
dusty logo you got the raid school
world's first last with players name
like engrave stuff for the people who
absolutely go and you want to talk about
a hard fight I'm pretty sure this is
gonna be like one because potentially
what I saw heads up small spoiler on
level numbers possible raid is gonna be
at the 550 okay okay
so if five to twenty two to the highest
this week you
probably one and a half more weeks of
resets mm-hmm maybe some more grinding
in there I mean they might be 545 but I
don't think they're gonna be over
leveled right so and I wonder if it's
gonna be one of those where you go in
and the raid is recommended 552 started
or 550 to finish it yeah that's gonna be
the question yeah this was a good
discussion to have it like you know 5 35
45 50 is like that's your levels of
stuff as you progress farther into the
raid and you get some stuff to help you
level up or do you straight up start a
550 in the top stuff was like hey you
could go into what was it crota you
could start at 30 but the room or at
least corrode it was like 32 or 33
they were Opie on top so I'm kind of
wondering how they're gonna do that
stuff versus us so yeah this is good
there but shout out shout out to Bungie
for this one man I thought oh you know
this is yeah this is something one thing
that I didn't realize is when I first
start playing testing was how you know
as you as you we grew with the game
right as we grew with you know aft
mm I'm blanking on the favor great to go
to greatest rate of all time the vault
of glass like help so you had the fall
of course you know same as I remember
when taking Kincaid and you know they're
gonna tell you the raid day and people
literally you know jumping in and trying
to get that level up right before the
raid and you it's just that fever pitch
of who's gonna first and then people
looking at each other streams oh these
guys are this far okay cool
it's something about raids that just
bring this community together and it's
just great to see and when you conquer
it and just seeing everybody's
experience it and I know that's one
thing destiny never gets wrong for the
most part is the raid right that you
always at the end of it people like oh
my god that was one of the most best
experiences you know as a like this was
amazing kudos Bungie wow this was
challenging and it's six players you
know the most about tell people who've
never played it destiny it is one of the
best cooperative experiences in gaming
I'm talking a lot of how probably today
y'all just like an awesome best music
and game that's it best cooperative
experiences in game
so you've done a 40-person rate in world
of warcraft
listen world of warcraft people i know
we come from y'all wrong 414 not
solutely and respect we got some work
I'm gonna a caveat I didn't say the best
cooperative console spirits like
first-person shooter like this type of
experience in a shooter though does not
exist it doesn't exist in different
level game and even the raids aren't 40%
anymore but mhm like that is the type of
I mean you go I mean a raid in World of
Warcraft was 10 bosses though mm-hmm 10
full-on fights absolutely or that and
that's was like but was you with the
first person shooting in that did you
have your abilities in there did you
have classes I'll be on you got your
classes stuff like that but you don't
I'm saying like the graphical scope it's
just two different games it's just
called oh I mean they are but I was like
that's kind of piece is all but Oh blow
bilities you had so many more abilities
than you can even imagine
dizzy don't you start with that arc
sorry to check bro don't you even dare
put talking to conversation no I'm
trying to remember what the title is
called it's like art I was a question I
nobody heard again what's the name it
was a game that wasn't like practice for
like are you I feel like you're having a
beverage over there something you are
like lit tonight I got my steak in a
good place right now but that's just
over here I'm checking with him when I
get home I was like I try and get off
early get home he's like hey it's like
what are you doing is like um well
Morgan I mean it's like I'm gonna grab a
snack I grab like something here sit
down he's like still go on like nine
minutes there's like dude what are you
nothing like what is taking you like you
had like half an hour to eat a meal that
shit's gotta be cold
as the luck I little feast man we had
the drinks we had to snake the shrimp
you know Lemon Drop martini got a fire
up the grill Oh wine I have to make this
an occasion this is a lordly a cage this
is forsaken weak we've waited for this I
have to celebrate what a lord like
banquet but guys yep the destiny - for a
second - soundtrack if you do the
campaign go get your destiny rewards you
will be able to get access to this
without buying it so shout out to
Michael Salvatori sky Lewin rode him
Moab and Peter
schlosser I'm probably butchering a
couple of those but all the composers on
those and this has like this has some
stuff in it - it's got Whisperer in
there it's got quite a few things so if
you want to get this soundtrack find
some way if you don't play it just buy
it the thing is kinda awesome to listen
to for like cinematic score type music
they did so so well
oh my god I'm good dad is literally
pre-ordered I've been getting that in
the grimoire book today I just didn't
want to get the grimoire a book by
itself I went a bit like a bulk order
and I might get a couple of shirts dude
there's gonna Bungie expect a package
it's going down baby from sending I'm
gonna sell out of a gram or so I'll ever
got a day one yeah you're smart I mean I
run I ran at risk of doing it but this
is for me the music is for me I mean
grimoire no disrespect of course I love
it the book looks great but that man is
soundtrack I need my soundtrack man I
need my cursor Osiris I need all of this
forsaken music the cave I think that
music for Kade and neon in the prison
and it's like go back in your cages oh
man mean everything they knocked it out
the box for caveman yeah I would say I
mean we knew it was happening man it was
done so well glorious glorious sort of
like literally to the to the bitter end
it was he's easy I mean I'm gonna you
really feel away like yeah I'm going to
miss him he was innocent
you know all the lightheartedness and
even even one guard in particular set a
comment that um regarding his death that
was just like that was dope
too bad she bit job some words with it
for the homie seriously like if you go
check with your vendors and stuff
they've all got a piece you talk to the
hell is her name what them know on
necess haven't gone SSU took those
things failsafe the failsafe that we
yeah first thing you do just go talk to
failsafe when you login turn all your
music up and just listen just listen
oh man all I remember
I don't recall Shack scene to exhaust
speak to shacks a lot I don't call him
see I don't think he did much hey say
what but you made glut banshee I was
like that's what's up XO de actually
it's tough but I know who didn't save
some stuff after the mission no just
call it dude
Zavala man we got words bro we got word
it's like again I was mad again mad
during the campaign but it's post
campaign he's just pissing on your
parade man oh man he just had me I'm
like boy let's ready one-on-one give me
five minutes that's back in the day we
should call people to pull them outside
five minutes bro we can settle this
outside because you know you don't know
this is a fantastic this is this is
great thank y'all for the chat a lot of
faces in the air gotta see this is good
this is the one piece we didn't want to
discuss with you guys it's kind of the
only piece that really matters besides a
couple there's a hotfix coming a little
stuff like that challenges and resets so
for you guys working on powerful gear
trying to get stuff as much as you can
basically what you're gonna want to do
is check what your your weekly
challenges are gonna be those you're
gonna have some bounties that are gonna
give you some powerful gear like a
spider he's gonna have one bounty that's
pretty damn my level right now which I
still gotta go try you're gonna get some
stuff from the dreaming city that's
gonna be there and then of course your
weekly reset like the flash point that
stuff still seems like it's gonna be do
your three strikes do your nightfall
they'll say weekly and that's exactly
how that's gonna stay but they've added
all these daily zero you're fine it's
fun daily challenges and their
rotational way to get you to do
different things but it's an additional
piece of powerful gear every day so
we're not on this piece that's like well
I've done my milestones for the week I
got nothing else literally log in the
next day so on Tuesday it was run one
strike you got a piece of gear and it
was powerful gear next day it was
playing ambit match and it's just once
quick daily challenge to get you to do
different stuff in the game but as
you're trying to level up and if you're
gonna do three characters good luck
keeping up like one is what its gonna
take for me for a while I haven't even
thought about it I don't even like I
don't even want to even get into that so
but it's like so they mentioned it's a
four day reset for the dailies so the
first daily strike challenge was Tuesday
so the next daily strike challenge will
be on Saturday and then they're gonna
have a whole calendar up honestly you
could put four things in a pret
spreadsheet you know add four days and
just have the next year which I may do
it so avoiding that they know long
gambit I was on Wednesday so the next
daily will be on Sunday yes crucible is
today it seems like so that would be
Monday I don't know what tomorrow's
would be brides of course yeah so I'm
actually gonna be out so actually if you
get it text me yes also as soon as er
comes out is lit we're leaving at 11:00
so I'm sorry professor yeah but just
text me with what he's got just so I
kind of have an idea he's gonna be key
he's gonna be key I'm very curious I
wanted I think they may go masticore oh
and I wouldn't I wouldn't necessary have
a problem with it I want to see him or
maybe maybe I think they're gonna do
something you know the currents at a bar
currency he will sell
thinking myself I don't know why my gut
is telling me this uh I could be wrong I
think he may sell based on you know it's
such a premium and they have to make him
relevant so we know all we knew was the
fated in games we knew three Accords
went away he's not gonna be selling
three cones he's not gonna be selling
the the nightfall scoring stuff number
that's retired so he's gonna be bounties
- I really hope he does yeah and think
about that what if Sir has bounties you
know I'm saying like I I am confident
something is going to be different with
old tangley face technical things over
there he's he's definitely definitely
going to have something different so I'm
actually looking forward to zur and we
can all clap look forward to finding
szura first where is there video because
I like that that's what I used to look
forward to you as well I'll be at work
you know with the old reset time when I
work nights and see if he passes that
okay here oh don't you start Sparrow
drives again I will say like the exotic
cosmetics and this one look really cool
like they have a couple of the coolest
and most unique models and stuff any of
you just some of the normal ships
they're like substantially different
this time around like they finally got
some creative liberties that like none
of the same three things like they're
giving some more variety but those
there's two or three exotics I gotta get
me at some point I gotta uh I actually
already got the chicken petting emote oh
yeah mine so that was like one of my
first ones that I got so check that box
off we've got the Robo basically
Shetty's or fire
[Laughter]
suck it up buttercup need to get on that
I see you distanced yourself from your
very real quick fireteam dude you don't
uh get I'm sorry but yeah I'm with you
on that one like dude that is your
fireteam we don't have any imminent
threats of breaking down the walls right
now go take care of that yeah I was
definitely a sucker moment god I gotta
put it up in a second moments of death
kind of wondering if he's gonna have
something when it like some pullback
moment that actually makes that
worthwhile I think so I think so because
again with the conversation you know
which you have with him post you know
what you call it you know K yeah that he
is in he is foreshadowing a lot do you
notice that absolutely yes I don't know
if it's like year three not sure how far
but he's definitely got something on
that - no respect oh yeah just watch out
for those dailies out there those are
gonna be your quickest way to help level
you up I don't know what tomorrow's
gonna be and then Saturday on strike so
basically it's every four days I kind of
wonder from my weekly reset if I'm just
gonna have to build a calendar for the
weeks you know what's your dailies
they're gonna be actually my weekly
reset videos are gonna be so if you guys
are listening or in chat right now kind
of a curious thing because when with the
reset comes we've got all of those
bounties to go hunt down from the
tangled short mm-hmm I've actually been
thinking about because I found most of a
minutes like I just didn't have enough
time this week but next week if I go
figure out where each ones that like do
okay this one's here this one's here
this one's here and just do a separate
video for like the spider bounties I
think that I might be late so yeah
Sparta Bonnie's yeah cuz actually one of
the big one all the loss sectors and
it's like well crap I don't remember
yeah we actually teased the big boy the
golden bounty that he goes I haven't
done that one yet I want to call it
insane oh my god
all the it's dynamic I mean I was like I
saw us our boy do it oh Jesus oh yeah
yes guys if you want to see like I did
solo night falls and stuff but yeah he
makes me look bad yeah just another
level at the 80 feet is just ridiculous
but shoutout him so I'm trying to think
where it is but it was yeah he did the
yeah he's so load the yeah blood cleaver
wanted bounty yeah so load it at 500 Wow
forty power bill levels below so it's
not immune but that's gonna be a long
fight so I'm gonna get back in town
something like that if I don't have the
whole day with my wife Wolsey other than
that little hotfix come in Bungie
rewards as I was talking about it's
basically they're uh little thing of
doing stuff in game I actually like it
it's kind of cool show you guys in a sec
but other than that are a few known
issues they talk about right now so
check those out if you're seeing a
giving major I don't think anything's
too crucial at the moment they just do
mention to receive proper gambit killed
credit for ace of spades quest line
players must defeat in invader five
times with a hand cannon so that it's
gonna be rough but other than that we
got some movies of the week and this is
the emblem for just the artists in the
community always putting out like
there's someone Twitter just some
awesome artists there's one of it
watching you does those like almost look
like black charcoal drawings is gonna be
faces yes yes peep that that's really
cool I forget his name like mono
Keeley's or something like that but yeah
all that stuff's cool and then this is
Bungie rewards so this is what I was
talking about get the soundtrack so
unlock the reward expires September 30th
so do it this month complete the
campaign once you do and it actually
checks it off so it's got a four second
original soundtrack whisper the warm
bonus digital track for unreleased stuff
it's got like this thing has just about
everything in it I think so I just love
whispers on there too because that isn't
yeah yeah cuz there's other stuff to
acquire ease of Spades details coming
soon
legendary so glory legend drink in rank
floors I don't know what what I mean
these are awards and this might be who
knows what you get for it there's
incentive for real stuff that you might
actually have to buy other ways for
actually just play in the game playing a
game absolutely
get all the lore complete all the
destination triumphs complete all the
Dreaming city tramps gambit complete all
lifetime valor and glory tribes that is
a crucible monster
yeah samasta and this is probably about
the raid yeah yeah clearly clearly just
if you're gonna play their game get a
little extra so I'm always down for that
nothing you have to buy just a cool
stuff so got you just eat their doctrine
with rampage hello mmm a couple arrived
I'm at a point okay so I talk desk auto
rifles feel weak at least a couple of I
got they don't feel strong like to the
point where it's kind of sad it's like
scouts I think still need some work
pulses I literally have not got one yet
oh wow guys I don't have a pulse rifle
with to my name I've got a few hand
cannons some sidearms
I got craps I don't they keep drowning
me in sidearms but no one pulse rifle
I got a 450 pose I got two actually two
pulses running on energy you want and
what you call it the rolls are gay I
will say right now rampage on anything
with any type of hole right there is
really strong now to tell you what Odle
I have that is ridiculous in crucible
the arm tell you right now hold on the
order that you need to get in the energy
slot is misfit all my lord 720 rpm I got
um believe I've got rampage on it and
like um I think like a quick draw
something like that just for fast
scoping and stuff like that
let's got it but it didn't feel powerful
in PvE I haven't done my WEP a great PvE
not
so much The Rifles feel real that's I
guess more or less talking I haven't
played in crucible so maybe that's it's
fit but in its advanced it takes like a
full clip or one hand and a bullet from
ten ten paces like I feel ten paces hand
cannon with time part time payload has
been good arm again the high scout ones
see I've gotten some really good rolls
man I've got like you know I've got like
scout this one I got like a it's a high
impact scout with full auto and I think
also rampage and that one is really sick
it's called on the cut and run
no yep nope cut and run is we actually I
don't have rampage really I excuse me
has triple tap and outlaw and it's a
beast in PvE that's about any Scout you
know saying so I got that going on Bulls
are really strong will agree with you oh
I haven't gotten any autos that are PvE
stronger I've got any high-impact autos
or any like you know Oh to autos that I
can compete with like origin story and
all that good stuff we used to have they
just both that one and ether doctor both
PvP or both auto rifles in PvE suck oh
yeah listen they're not they're not
damage dealers they're not yeah I got it
with your hair cans are better out of
the new stuff that I've seen
um but pulses have been strong you know
there's another one the right side of
wrong that's another really good strong
one anyplace decently enough in PvP but
it's really better in PvE I got a good
roll I feel sidearm so very strong
though even though I'm getting too many
of them vest was like yeah there was one
or two side I was using just in PvE and
I was like I'm actually killing stuff
like yeah one of the full autos and it
was leveling up a random blue one until
I kind of over leveled out I was like
dude yeah like I don't know if I've seen
a submachine gun either I've got stuff I
got one bad reputation that's really
good
I mean side missing like art types right
now that's how much my rosalyn going man
and I don't have a legendary rocket
launcher yet I mean I won my first
legendary sword I didn't get a sword yet
I've got one legendary rocket it was
owned let me tell you what the hockey
legendary rock rocket launches are
really nice man
because the tracking is a little bit
better when on a zoom in and gone I just
wish I had one more cluster bomb
something like that but I don't know if
they roll like that but not gonna get
tracking him it would think it was on
Guardian right it was at a k-dub remark
mmm a hawk a tracking cluster see that's
gonna be to God roll like jockeys are
the move now like the tracking is much
better you lock in and hit him and then
you just let go boom grenade launchers
good lord
good luck Renee launches are back they
are back here in the same yeah I got one
that was the sticky though didn't even
realize that I was like dude - it was
like oh crap wrong type at the moment so
though for a second but yeah but see
that's one of those things that kind of
bugs me though a little bit if you say
misfit is that good and crucible and
that bad in PvE how does that diskin how
does that happen how is that that far
off balance just one of those things
that makes me still wonder like hmm I
don't know how they how they screw the
pooch on one end so bad but you guys say
it just melts on the other side I'm like
cuz it feels like trash in PvE like it
takes me a [ __ ] I mean I should question
one hit on the same guy with ten paces I
feel you do you have ramp agent no but
that wouldn't matter if it's just a gun
- gun like rampage is gonna come after
kill I'm talking normal I under pressure
and I have tapped the trigger I'm just
talking a straight normal kill time you
know I hear you I mean did not did not
in that dominant place
I'm bias I'm probably the wrong person
to ask on that one because you know no
oh oh okay use your one with rampage
take a hand cannon your primary spot
right you're right but I'm like this try
it
I'm not arguing that you're absolutely
right on that that the ten pace is gonna
doubt beat that in PvE all time what I'm
saying is that archetype that you're
talking about is a 720 those don't hit
hard so what it is is I haven't
seen any new any other oils outside of
that archetype that are new I'm saying
like I've got to see it yeah I've got to
see but I would seem like a 450 or a 600
each I'm saying we've just gotten that
700 and it's you know you know it shoots
fast it's like doctrinal passing a weak
doctrine of passing in PvE
but in PV PvP I'm telling you take that
same gun in there and you're gonna see
what I'm talking about so I think just
what it is is we haven't seen those
different archetypes on the new weapons
yet and I'm hoping they're there I don't
know the whole weapon seems to be a lot
of variety from what I'm saying so far
I'm seeing a lot so hopefully like I
said those are drawn maybe it's like a
gun gunsmith kind of things I see I had
a lot of gunsmith arm materials coming
in and I also have the what I would
advise if you have used valid you've
prestiged your your valid right I did it
previously but haven't done it yet this
time I mean this is under one I'd have
you done the second one when you get the
shell yeah I did get that one okay that
shells very important because it's the
only shell that like really increases
gunsmith stuff from all sources so you
can literally just leave that shell on
and you'll get almost double
we're in conjunction I don't know if
it's officially double gunsmith
resources but it's way better than any
other kosher and what happens is in any
activity crucible Vanguard strikes
whatever you're doing it's gonna give
you more and then I keep going to him
and maybe I think he is the source of
giving me these better guns that I'm
seeing so maybe you want to give that a
shot and see if you mean I have like
4,800 weapon parts so Oh bro got a
couple and I've got a few but I just
haven't I've been waiting to like dump
them yet just to see but honestly dude
my shell because like that's like I'm
good on most materials starmap shell man
- caches on every plane over the 50
meter meter range and glimmer gain I'm
just rolling the whole time every planet
50 meter range map shell it's an exotic
that just came through at some point it
was some previously gear one thing and
generate consonants and limitary on any
elemental weapon kill all the range
increase glimmer and a gunsmith now it's
not increased telemetry but it's on any
weapon type that's that's that's yeah
that's good that's good yeah that's
that's my ghost that just sits there so
mm-hmm yeah man chapter zero yep love
misfit love keeper dr. great guns man
yeah I've got both of those don't have
great rolls I don't think so yeah I
begin transfer I haven't gotten any
bolts that's another thing like people
coming no I have the basic bow and I
think I leveled it up and fused it once
just like it's still toy around with it
but no haven't got any I've seen um I
guess I shout the Fonz he's gotten one
would rant I heard rampage gonna bow is
crazy zero he's saying Cerberus plus one
things I've seen the exotic but I don't
have it um you know there's a lot
there's a lot of stuff out there man so
but I like that it's still we're still
in a discovery phrase still trying to
figure out which horses are you know
stay and different weapon archetypes and
stuff like that but um yeah is give us
some time give us some time I think I
think we just haven't seen your
archetype because I right now 720s have
never been in a good place in PvE you
know never just the only two auto rifles
of God so just know hopefully this is
the other like I said you probably like
a 450 or like a 600 that will drop and
then we kind of test it out because that
would be more comparable to the classic
d2 autos that actually did damage you
know I'm saying because all origin story
was 450 goes primus was 600 um we've got
the other ones you know you got a uh um
you know positive outlook and euros gear
for last like that 450 those that seems
to be I'm assuming those are type of
autos that you had success with it that
you liked yeah pretty much
so immature hopefully they should still
be in there huh well I think we're at
about two hours yeah we made long point
oh yeah
honestly for me Tigers but I haven't
seen
mm much to do I've got to dive into the
city more when I get back like Sunday if
I'll probably still be hanging out with
my wife because I won't see her for a
couple days yeah so it's gonna be
there's so much to do the rate is coming
I'm not gonna be ready it's really not
gonna be ready I know I'm not hey it's
all good bags got stuff to do do things
at your own pace there's ton of the tons
to do even if you're not like level
ready you can still do other question
get the right you know weapons and
slowly gear yourself up for a part you
know for powerful gear as well as exotic
west madness there's a lot of stuff to
do a lot of stuff to do
oh yeah zero screeching this Tiger spy
he said it's in the dreamers city I'm I
had to get it I got all I got from dream
city was an armor so I got to see what
that's about to know yeah I got I got a
scout rifle it's kind of garbage uh 200
rpm scout rifle it's got a full sub
payload which isn't bad did that get
fixed by the way or no it's explosive
payload was nerfed pre yeah I was like
three patch patch even before even
before the last two patches that was
nerve but it's got rifle with hip fire
grip which is just awful yeah you just
got some bad rolls you are in Jesus as a
member I can tell about what you're
saying because like I'm tell you right
now though timed payload is now like are
they've done something to time pay low
because when you hit their initial
damage and then it's like a delay and
then you see that second proc of a
number and that can kind of finish off a
lot of red bars and I'm telling I'm
loving time payload right now I don't
even know what that is yeah I don't know
if it's new but time payload and rate
seen that person let's say you're
shooting a red bar right yeah shoot a
red bar the initial shot hits tremendous
damage but then a split second later you
see a yellow flash of an additional
damage count so it's like a delayed
explosion off of every hit with your
primary I mean or whatever weapon you're
using well yeah I have it on a scow and
I have it
what you called on ten paces and I can't
stop using that hand cannon like it's so
it hits like a truck already it's strong
already but with that time payload like
you're really ripping through enemies
and it does fairly good damage against
your little bar and stuff and bosses and
stuff like that with consistent DPS it
is solid I really love that part it was
like my ten paces of quicker on Zen
moment which is kinda okay and then I've
got you're getting amazing crucible
perks those perks I've been using in the
crucible those ungodly shout out to zero
on the time payload was on the yes it
was the only one that I believed at it
true prophecy yes cuz me and Chi Batson
was talking about it that's where the
hand cannon from future war call so if
you got that's time paying low it's
really good because I was I wasn't
future Walker sorry no but yeah I am
loving that oh really good but yeah like
Mullen target all that stuff that you
got bro your your crucible ready like
I'm listening to your roles oh my god
moving target tactical mag and true same
brawl basis that is amos cyst move
assist like you are hunting someone down
with headshots with those roles apply I
can get my ace of spades whenever I
finally get to do it without probably
spoiling too much stuff just a lot of
hype canna get in there have some fun
yes just shut a door order some pizza
drink up actually don't order pizza have
some real food like kognito have a feast
don't snack just drink lots of water
have some real food cooked food don't go
with the crap go freestyle proper the
shrimp at stake
make it a treat and then don't sleep
that's it I have a treat and don't sleep
well I'm gonna be out for a couple of
days so I'm gonna miss dessert I don't
even know if I'll do a video when I get
back but I will have to zero is like
another hour
can I just have what you guys are on cuz
I'm literally gonna try and get up in
about four and a half hours and workouts
I'm already gonna drag ass all the way
through that excitement man well yeah
believe me I want to play right now and
I know I should go right to bed but I
would like I won't log in and like play
just a little bit I'm gonna go through
something but like I got that itch no
I'm loving it is it perfect no game is
not I don't know no game is perfect but
did they nail a nine out of ten for me
so far yeah absolutely absolutely and
I'm like I said I'm an early review is
that just when a reserved judgment even
though I'm super confident in the rate I
just want to see the rain I want to see
how it's done if they do that which I'm
extremely confident and nail that then
then we can start talking destiny
expansion Pantheon talk start that real
discover do a flash point you know rate
will be the determinate if it beats yeah
yeah that that's how we know the big bar
I mean though the Kings a Barton yeah 10
Kings a bar and when I read articles
like task he just dropped one today mmm
they're taking King moment it's it lived
to the but when I hear the detractors
the people who are very hard on destiny
give it its due they're doing something
right so let's see next week last wish
I'm ready gonna get the team together
get this thing popping man huh all right
well I'd say that pretty much wraps it
up guys
for me hit me up everywhere thanks to
all you guys that participated in the
giveaway got a few new viewers watchers
and other type things but yeah got a
couple what I was trying to do for the
giveaway is do a full year of year two
to somebody
so again year two annual pass and
forsaken the guy who I drew first ended
up saying hey I've got it on Xbox so
it's like okay well so I'm gonna get him
the annual pass so I reached out and
drew another guy was like hey i've got
an annual pass going out but i want to
do a full so I was like what can I do
for the
you forsake him he's like oh I don't
actually have it yet so I got him credit
on PlayStation but then the other guy
came back as opposed thinking about
going on PC but he played on xbox the
whole time
so I ended up buying him just that all
the collection except Daniel pass I did
him the full year one and forsaken
collection on PC so ended up giving away
a little more but a couple people out
there and it was cool so I went yeah I
was the guy who won the first one I
think I told you but I didn't send it to
anybody else he lives where I work he
was liked here whatever city is like I
mean no city could be ten minutes big
but he's like he probably works the more
than twenty minutes from my house Wow
he's like at some point I want to be
like hey let's just say hey because he's
that close and then dizzy I figured out
did not even know cuz he actually did
the drawing and I had cities and you
know like dizzy he's probably about 45
minutes from me tell you the Texas
two-step BAM I'm coming back we got all
hey you're gonna come down we got to do
like a live 50 if we do hundred but we
got to do a live one yes absolutely
I'll be down for a map so we got we got
Panda we got SWAT Texas two-step man we
gotta definitely puppet man love it love
it down there worth out here in Texas
absolutely I am down for that bro so
alright guys so for me it's twitch
Twitter YouTube a bond has everywhere
subscribe follow enjoy the fun lots of
income what about you sir
Lord cockney obviously you already know
the iron law podcast will return on
Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern the inner
circle Network we're gonna have a level
designer on game level designer Luis
Yepez and he's worked on a lot of times
you may not have known as well as done
level design forearm state of decay -
they actually worked on that as well so
just get some pick his brain and get
this he he's a huge destiny Fair we'll
just wrap up I'll be being destiny in
him that's all that matters this week
next week you can talk about anything
you know desk these on the docket you
know so please check tune in to that
I'll be all Newtown
11 a.m. Eastern because for football you
know it's been the meet anyway that's
why I set it up like that because I do
their reaction was gonna get awesome
oh yeah the 11:00 a.m. Eastern we're
gonna rock like that for football season
for a while and you know until
everybody's teams are eliminated by like
January February go back to one you know
it's for fantasy football purposes
primarily so we got dad so you know
please tune in for Louisa it's gonna be
good obviously on our North podcast I
mean the UM all the other content here
you can find flashpoint as well as other
iron lore podcast content will be also
on the island podcast YouTube channel
and on Twitter I am Lord Cognito also
one thing I got a remind I gotta say
before shout the Lord snow though we're
doing on the iron wall podcast channel
Friday tomorrow at 7 p.m.
well actually technically today because
he's um he's doing a giveaway scum
giveaway for the PC game scum it's
fantastic it's all flat like kind of
like pub G slash fortnight mould battle
but also much deeper a lot of our
systems deep systems on put it this way
the game like you have to manage
everything about the character but you
could even do a number one and the
number two if you're saying based on
resources and stuff like that so it's a
really good game we got a chance to
preview it Lawson Aldo is gonna be doing
that on the iron law podcast twitch
channel 7 p.m. and I got the links in
description also the video is up
promoting that so please tune in get a
chance to win a game on PC if you're on
PC start by hanging with the Lords the
stream team and that's what we got going
on this Friday 7 p.m. est the hype man
if you ever need to get hyped up call
this man do it inferior to everything he
says you can't live up to it but how you
feel for a second
preciate you run breezy to big dead
alright as well thank you for the late
stream it's your gonna play all damn
night
Sol yeah he's ready he's got that
vampire life and he's already lost
I'm fueled up I got my drink I'm ready
when are you drinking got asking for we
go I'm gonna punch you in the coconuts
Rock we got a little pineapple smoothie
humid tropical for the summer right now
summer months and but you know we gotta
we gotta keep things so it's a little
little flavor vodka you know that kind
of thing I'm doing it straight tonight
normally I go straight but I'm trying to
be tuned in for about on on tilt there
sir you know of nice feeling good
feeling good right yes sir
strikes you to Jay Jay oh man so
old-school
I forgot we Jay stands for me it's
actually good drink up in a second well
thank you guys it's been awesome enjoy
the grind try and get sleep here and
there maybe shower occasionally be
decent humans brush your teeth good
stuff in that chair change your
underwear please all those good things
do that because if you're living in that
chair you gotta get some stuff keep them
clean remember have clean underwear
[Music]
thank you have Mac Walden get that
underwear so antimicrobial underwear all
right guys I think we're out it's been
awesome we'll see y'all soon have a good
one please